Okay, let's talk about Tabular Data. You're
probably familiar with spreadsheet applications like Microsoft Office's
Excel, or Calc from Apache OpenOffice, or
even Google Spreadsheets. So with any one of
these applications. We can create tabular data
in the form of spreadsheet. So I'm a
big Beatles' fan, indulge me as we begin
a little data wrangling with some discography data.
After all, I'm sure even space cowboys
will be listening to Beatles' someday. Okay,
so as data scientist were usually concern
with what items a dataset contains and what
fields. Those items have. As I'm sure
you're aware, with tabular data, each row represents
a data item. And, an individual item can have one or more fields. The columns
each represent a different field. And in most tabular data, the very first row
will actually label those fields in some
way. Finally, we have an individual cell
that contains a value for a particular field. In this case the label for
this particular album is capital records in Canada. Okay so just to look at that
again in a more abstract sense. Each row is an item in our data set. Each column
makes up the fields for the data items. And finally, individual values for a
field are stored in cells. In the videos
that follow, we'll quickly get our hands study
working with tabular data in the CSV and
Excel data formats in the Python programming language.